welcome back to the special edition of
Hannity the Supreme Court issued the
final rulings of its term last week and
don't we know it causing several liberal
meltdowns in the process the Court's
decision to end race-based affirmative
action in college admissions did not go
over well with the left here's what AOC
is now saying should happen to the court
in retaliation
the Supreme Court is far overreaching
their Authority and I believe frankly
that we really need to be having
conversations about judicial review as a
check on the courts as well there also
must be impeachment on the table we have
a broad level of tools to deal with
misconduct overreach and abuse of power
and the Supreme Court has not been
receiving
the adequate oversight necessary in
order to preserve their own legitimacy
and in the process they themselves have
been destroying the legitimacy of the
Court oh boy over on MSNBC Joy Reid
mourned the loss of what she openly
claims is the only thing that got her
into Harvard take a look
well let me just be clear I got into
Harvard only because of affirmative
action I went to a school no one had
ever heard of in Denver Colorado in a
small suburb I didn't go to Exeter or
Andover I didn't have college test prep
I just happened to be really nerdy and
smart and have really good grades a good
SAT scores but someone came to Denver
Colorado to look for me a Harvard
recruiter flew to Denver and I met up
with her at the Village Inn Restaurant
and did a pre-interview to get to route
to pull me into Harvard I wasn't I was
pulled in and the school's like
affirmative bill that I got into
affirmatively
well there you go some on the left are
even fighting back Harvard is now facing
a civil rights complaint from left-wing
groups over its legacy admissions
process which they claim unfairly
advantages white students and more
lawsuits could be coming former senior
adviser to president Trump Stephen
Miller just sent a letter to the Deans
of 200 law schools around the country
warning them that he will file suit if
they continue to consider race in the
admissions process Stephen Miller joins
me now along with author of the new book
trial of the century Greg Jarrett and
host of the just listen to yourself
podcast our friend Kara Davis I thank
you all for joining me on this day
before independence day but what a great
time to talk about the the condition the
country's in Stephen let me start with
you because you know this that we know
that the universities colleges are just
not going to give up they're going to
find another way to do this and the UC
Davis Medical School seems to be a
template for them in some way and that
they have a a template regarding people
who are disadvantaged and then that kind
of moves you right to the front and of
course the presumption is there that
that's that's going to bring in the the
people uh you know maybe who are people
of color but certainly perhaps are more
inclined to move along uh the leftist
agenda Etc uh where do you think is this
going to stop or is this going to take
more lawsuits and is it going to be a
big a big problem
everything you've said Tammy is
completely correct so UC Davis as an
example uses a disadvantage score they
prioritize applicants who say they've
experienced more disadvantages but
they're just using that as a proxy for
race to achieve a racial balancing test
so what you're going to see because the
left test they have no respect for the
Supreme Court I mean you heard the quote
from AOC what left-wing universities are
going to do is they're going to create
all these proxy tests all of these
pre-texts but they are trying to achieve
the same racial balancing to keep poor
whites out to keep Asians out to try to
have an artificial racial lens for
admissions that is illegal that is
unconstitutional the Supreme Court has
held that that is illegal and
unconstitutional so my organization
America First legal sent a warning
letter to every single law school in
America and next we're going to do
medical schools and after that we're
also going to do undergraduate schools
and we've said if you continue to use a
racial balancing test by hook or crook
by any means to try to stack the deck
towards One race in admissions then we
are going to take you to court because
in this country it doesn't matter what
your skin color is racial bigotry is
wrong you know it's it also relies
especially the disadvantage template it
relies on that being maintained that if
you're going to only be able to get into
a college because you you have been
disadvantaged in various elements of
society there is then an incentive
to be disadvantaged uh it which is a
horrible Dynamic Greg you know we've
we've got here especially with AOC uh
it's interesting that you know she wants
to do impeachments and everything but
there were a number of of decisions from
the Supreme Court that the left liked
like on immigration and we didn't hear
them complaining about how horrible the
Supreme Court was when they got the the
decisions they liked uh is is this
though what we're going to be hearing
from the left and does she have any
credibility when she's calling for
impeachments or anything else
no AOC should do something novel and
actually read the Constitution because
her criticism is uninformed it's the
core duty of the Supreme Court under
article 3 to decide whether
constitutional rights are being violated
that's exactly what the high court did
in all three cases decided this week and
disliking the result doesn't make it an
abusive power as she claims indeed it's
the opposite the justices
halted an abusive power that
transgressed the rights of citizens
under the First Amendment the 14th
Amendment the article two duty of
congress to tax and spend and the loan
forgiveness decision I mean AOC is
arguing against yourself only Congress
holds the power of the purse not the
president he can't act unilaterally by
executive Fiat but Acacia Cortez and
other Democrats seem all too willing to
give up their own authority and
relevancy by handing it over to Joe
Biden that is not how our constitution
is written you know Kara a lot of people
don't know that and a lot of people and
as a direct result of the left
controlling the school system for a
couple of generations creating a kind of
ignorance that allows them it's very
clever that allows them to keep people
ignorant and to make claims that are not
true and to just gin people up your
activism as a mom and and in your town
is real has also been based in education
you've seen what's been going on there
at the local level you know is this the
kind of thing that people understand
because all we hear is oh this is racism
and you want to keep people out whereas
in fact these decisions are classical
liberal decisions you know about freedom
of expression about who about not using
race which means we then would have to
go to the root cause of why SAT scores
for young people of color are lower than
the SAT scores for whites but they don't
want to do that do they
well no quite obviously I mean we've
seen that even with what's happened over
the last three years with covid how so
many education departments including the
federal department don't want to release
education numbers and the results
because they know they were wrong and
that's what the results will show of
course it's so much easier to say look
at what these evil Republicans are doing
this is racism black people will never
be able to achieve anything because I
guess we can't achieve anything unless
we have our white saviors on the left do
exactly for us of course that's easy to
say it makes a great headline and you
can it's shareable on Tick Tock but it's
way outside of reality but what do we
expect young people like David Hogg who
tweeted the other day that it's not fair
that a million people get to decide who
the scotus is for 30 million people a
complete misunderstanding of the
electoral college but of course we are
building ignorant minds and that is
because those are the people who will be
susceptible to hysterics like we're
seeing come coming from AOC what she
just said is so incredibly ignorant and
ridiculous it's sad that she is a
representative in the United States
government but that is the generation
that is being built by the public
education system and aided by the
progressive media we need to re-educate
our kids towards patriotism that's how
we Orient them towards patriotism so
that we don't have these panicked
headlines people understand what
happened the Supreme Court is not
discriminating the Supreme Court is
removing discrimination it's a great
points Kara Stephen your work when we
think about the lives that are ruined
when someone is going being ushered
through the the university system and
doesn't can't do it doesn't understand
how to do it and then there's chaos in
personal lives because you've either
that's why everybody wants their money
back on school loans because it's like
they got a lemon I mean this is about
saving lives of the people that have
been rely relying on Democrat policy for
50 years now
it must be very clear about something
everybody is worse off as a result of
the racialized race-based admissions
process we have in universities when a
university emits a student of any race
that is not a match for the particular
academic policies of that University the
academic levels of that University you
have higher Dropout rates you have worse
academic performance and you have worse
professional performance as a result of
that rather than having the goal of
matching the student to the institution
and then you have students who sacrifice
who don't get into the school they
deserve and then what does that do it
tells other students not to sacrifice
for their rights everyone loses let me
just tell you Karen Davis I want you to
be the education secretary for whoever
the next Republican president is going
to be because we got to get to the root
cause fired we got to get to the root
cause about how what's going on with our
Public Schools all right everyone thank
you very much hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube age and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else